christophe dans cette on parlait des
sanctions il ya un instant elles sont
fortes elles sont massives mais les
ukrainiens sont déçus à commencer par le
président lui-même ils sont déçus parce
que ces sanctions on connaîtra plus tard
la liste exacte on sait que visent avant
tout des banques des exportations de
haute technologie des personnalités des
des oligarques mais le président
ukrainien où didier il a demandé à
plusieurs reprises et encore il ya
quelques instants sur instagram il
demandait que la russie soit couper du
système de messagerie swift il dit il ya
quelques minutes un il dit que la
pression sur la russie doit encore
s'intensifier il vise très clairement
l'autre 8 mai sur ce point il n'a pas
été entendu alors c'est quoi
concrètement ce système swift dont on
parle alors c'est comme son acronyme le
dit bien c'est la traduction
de l'anglais c'est un système de
télécommunication interbancaire mondial
en clair c'est une messagerie entre les
banques est né dans les années 70 en
belgique à l'origine en 1973 conseil
décret et c'était 200 banques
aujourd'hui ce sont plus de 11 mille
établissements financiers qui sont
reliés entre eux alors concrètement
c'est un code un code qu'on connaît bien
puisque quand on joue pas si vous
regardez temps en temps votre relevé
d'identité bancaire et ben il ya ce code
qui parfois s'appelle le bic le leberg
international bing code qui est donc ça
signifie que quand il ya une personne ou
une entreprise qui veut envoyer de
l'argent à une autre entreprise et bien
elle va passer par sa banque évidemment
qui va elle passer un message en
utilisant ce swift pour passer à le
message l'autre banque et qui va lui
dire ça y est on a bien on a bien reçu
le message que vous allez recevoir de
l'argent donc c'est un système sécurisé
alors avant on utilisait quoi le fax et
si les entreprises ce russe sont coupés
de swift débat il va falloir retrouver
ses messageries anciennes donc soit on
passe par un mail soit on passe par un
fax mais dans tous les cas c'est pas
sécurisé et en 2012 et 2018 ce système
de coups de couper un pays du swift a
déjà été utilisé pour l'iran et à chaque
fois ça a fait mal pour l'iran sera
coupée l'iran d'environ 30 % de ses
exportations
et pourquoi elle et les européens n'ont
pas pris cette mesure pour l'instant et
bien parce qu'ils sont divisés sur ce
point les pays baltiques certains pays
de l'est veulent eux que effectivement
ce soit le cas quand on coupe la russie
du swiss mais l'allemagne et l'italie en
particulier sont deux pays qui freine
ils redoutent les conséquences pour
leurs propres économies parce qu'ils
dépendent beaucoup du gaz russe et la
france plus que la france notamment est
d'ailleurs la france est plutôt pour
couper le swift car si gazprom par
exemple ne peut plus être payés
à cause de ce à cause de ce 2 de ce
manque de swift et bien il enverra pas
de gaza c'est ça ne fait pas de doute
d'ailleurs le ministre des finances
allemand christian lindner quitter il a
bien fait comprendre ce matin ils
étaient accueillis par bruno le maire à
bercy pour une réunion des ministres des
finances européens et il n'a pas dit
autre chose en écoute
toutes les options sont sur la table
mais nous avons déjà mis en place un
blocage total des banques russes et que
chef ça veut dire les échanges
commerciaux avec la russie sont
quasiment suspendu
certains cas néanmoins il ya encore des
transactions par exemple pour payer les
livraisons de gaz une fois que les
entreprises allemands puissent
communiquer avec leurs filiales en
russie
allait plus loin et nous devons
réfléchir conséquence il s'agit de faire
payer la russie et son écho de nouveau
ce chercheur
il faut préciser que christiane ziegler
il est du fdp que c'est un libéral et
que c'est quand même au sein du
gouvernement il ya des tiraillements
entre les verts les écologistes et les
libéraux et le spd par rapport à la
condition comme ça voilà alors alors
justement est ce que pour les